okay so joker volume 2 is for the most
part done i don't know exactly how long
it's going to go on for uh but what i
did want to do here originally i was
going to cover like the whole volume uh
but i want to cover this part separate
because this is a pretty big deal and in
fact not only are we going to get the
origin of bain's daughter dc is actually
going to switch up the origin of bane a
little bit so i'm curious to see how
people react to this uh so having said
that what we initially do here is we
pick up in santa prisca right in
pinadura and basically there's a kind of
tour that's taking place here by the
masters of santa prisca now that's one
of the things that i do want to point
out here keep in mind with the joker
series it's the joker off doing his
thing and we're not exactly sure what it
is that he's getting into i mean we know
he's like creating mischief and causing
problems and killing people doing stuff
that the joker does and the story
largely follows commissioner gordon
tracking down the joker but there are
other characters in this right like
oracle uh barbara gordon of course being
like an information broker things like
that uh that you have like the daughter
of bane who's hot on uh joker's trail
although we're not entirely sure why
she's after him although we will find
out in the story there's kind of a lot
of things going on here besides just the
joker but one of the big differences for
a lot of people who came from like the
christopher nolan batman trilogy for
example bane as he was introduced in the
dark knight rises was of course a
prisoner of santa prisca but that it was
basically a hole in the ground and there
wasn't really anybody running the prison
it was just one of those things where if
you can somehow manage to escape and
most people die trying then you can gain
your freedom you can just leave uh santa
prisco wasn't really always that way not
in the comics it actually had like
masters of santa cris it had warden we
had a warden they had people who would
like keep control of it and make sure
people didn't escape there were big
differences between really between bane
as he was depicted in the comics and
even in the dark knight rises but
nonetheless what's basically going on
here is that a kind of marketer has been
brought in by the masters of santa
prisca for the purpose of like marketing
the prison and the reason why is because
bane is a well-known person out there in
the just out there in the world if for
no other reason than the fact that he's
the man who broke the bat but the other
part of that is the reputation bane
gained for himself in santa frisco
rather one of the big things about the
prison is that because of where it was
located when the tides came in the
waters would fill the cell of bane so he
literally just had to swim almost
constantly to keep himself from drowning
and so one of the things this did is it
beefed up his his resiliency it beefed
up his popularity and his reputation
among the prisoners because beyond that
anybody who came call and trying to
start problems with bane would meet a
pretty unfortunate faith and so he built
up the reputation that he was not
someone to be messed around with in the
criminal underworld that spread then
once he went to gotham city figured out
batman's identity in three months and
then broke his back he was basically
this just worldwide phenomenon in the
sense that like criminals out there
everywhere knew who he was now you build
on top of that the events of like i am
bane from dc rebirth and all that kind
of stuff everybody knows who he is and
the masters of santa prisca want to be
able to capitalize on that they quite
literally want to turn santa prisca
prison into a theme park meets alcatraz
it's quite literally how it's phrased
that like imagine alcatraz had like a
theme park in it and that's basically
what they want to do which just sounds
ridiculous the problem with all this is
that in the middle of this conversation
this marketer's phone goes off which
she's not supposed to have one in fact
they searched her to make sure she
didn't have one at that point they start
freaking out and the question is well
does she have weapons and they literally
start shooting at her now of course
while they're shooting at her she's
talking to barbara gordon and the
reality here is that batman doesn't know
that barbara gordon is contacting this
girl now of course this girl just kind
of runs and flees and dodging bullets
and all that kind of stuff while she's
having a conversation but the reality
here is that barbara gordon needs
information from santa prisca there's a
kind of mission that she needs this girl
to go on she's like well i'm already
here so let me take care of this right
let me get rid of these guys or at least
deal with these guys and then we'll go
from there and so ultimately once they
corner her they ask the question like
why would you be so foolish is to bring
a phone in here knowing what would
happen who do you possibly think you are
and that's when we find out this girl's
julia pennyworth now we haven't seen
hide nor hair from julia pennyworth in
quite some time
but remember the biggest reason why
julia pennyworth is basically here at
santa prisca and the reason why she has
it out for the masters of santa frisca
again her identity as a marketer
basically being a ruse is because bane
killed alfred remember that from like
the whole i am bane like all that stuff
you killed him in front of damien and
that's one of the things that they just
they never forgave him for now the
reality here is that julia is also not
really a friend of batman of the bat
family and the reason why is because
essentially the bad family was worn by
bane after he had conquered gotham city
and then he had alfred in his possession
he basically told all of them if any of
you enter into gotham city i will kill
alfred damien basically ignored it and
he thought he could sneak into gotham
city somehow get past bain which didn't
happen he got caught and the price for
his actions was the death of alfred and
so in a lot of ways julia looks at the
entirety of the batman family and says
you're the reason alfred's death but
switching over to uh to commissioner
gordon who's basically being held for
interrogation giving everything that
happened in the first volume of the
joker that he just kind of muses to
himself a little bit right where he was
ultimately caught by interpol the
international police it was just kind of
like okay so like they've got me in this
room they've got this giant mirror this
is just this is what cops always do
right you know like they're literally
watching me to see if i reveal anything
or whatever it is because the way this
works is that if he says anything
incriminating in the presence of himself
without a lawyer there that can be used
that can be used against him not only
that it's just it's an old interrogation
tactic right wait them out make them
hungry make them exhausted make them you
know make them desire for water that
kind of a thing right just kind of play
games but ultimately the door ends up
opening up and of course that's when
gordon's like look like i get i'm here
in interpol but come on police tactics
or police tactics no matter where you go
in the world right everybody borrows the
tactics of everybody else this is some
old game so let's drop the ruse and
let's just talk about what's going on
here right like i mean we were doing
this kind of stuff when i was younger
and so he's just kind of like okay tell
me about this laboratory that exists out
there that the joker had something to do
with somewhere along the line and the
way this is explained by her is she says
this laboratory which we'll talk about
more we'll talk about the significance
of it as we get further into this
because it ties directly into the origin
of bane's daughter but what she
basically says is that there is a knife
out there that has the fingerprints of
jim gordon on it and that the knife was
basically used to eviscerate three
scientists in that laboratory and that
what had happened is that interpol
basically for the last little while they
weren't really messing with jim gordon
standing on the other side of the glass
what they were looking to do was see if
they could find some way to verify
whether or not jim gordon had actually
done this and that what they had done is
that with the the murders matching a
series of murders committed by the joker
the mo and the way at which it was done
matches the joker's philosophy so unless
jim gordon has split personalities one
of which is the joker
there makes no sense that jim gordon
would be the one to do this unless he
was committing a series of murders and
trying to make it look like it was the
joke what ended up happening is interpol
basically contacted renee montoya who of
course you guys know was at one point
the question i don't know if she still
is i think she's just a detective who
works at the gotham city police
department again which kind of sucks
because i always thought like during the
new 52 she was just a great question
like i loved her as the question but the
whole thing about this is that they they
basically say look like we talked to her
she essentially corroborated or
exonerated you right she was like
there's no way jim gordon would do this
not only that of course you were
basically eating or you were you were
somewhere else at the time this happened
so we know it's not you at that point
she asked the question have you ever
heard about an organization called the
network now this is one of the things
that dc does and in reality it comes off
the heels of the court of owls this is
the reason why scott snyder's batman run
was so landmark when it happened scott
snyder was not by any standard of
measurement the first person to ever
think of an idea of some shady criminal
organization operating behind the scenes
that no one knows about but the way he
wrote the court of owls and the way it
was handled his entire batman run it was
landmark it to this day it's considered
outside of neil adams and dennis
o'neil's run depending on who you talk
to some people may say it is the single
greatest batman run but the impact of
the court of owls was so big that in
fact the court of al's concept lived on
in dc comics they didn't necessarily
have the same significance they had in
the batman story but it led into things
like the network and things along those
lines and this is when the questions
asked or at least when jim gordon says
like he's heard about them once in
passing right that he had met a man from
the cia when he was assembly
commissioner who told him that gotham
villains sometimes get free vacations
paid for by a cabal of criminals that
keeps itself hidden from the superheroes
that the joker has taken them up on the
offer a number of times and that when
the questions asked did you see one of
these vacation spots when you were in
belize the response of of jim gordon is
no i found joker at a private residence
i could tell you exactly where he is if
you give me my phone but what did they
do in this laboratory and the response
is they cloned human tissue illegally
now this is a funny thing because the
way in which the the network is
basically operating is by cloning human
tissue what it does is it gives various
people out there some of whom are just
ultra wealthy people who commit white
collar crime operating behind the scenes
it basically gives them the ability to
frame someone or someone like the joker
or someone like twoface or the riddler
or a penguin or lex luthor or whoever by
any number of these people out there who
basically want to utilize the benefits
of the network they want to commit a
series of crimes but they don't want to
be caught for it they can leave tissue
samples behind maybe for example they
can plant somebody else's skin under the
fingernails of one of their victims and
then walk away and so somebody else
basically gets framed for the crime now
of course the response of jim gordon is
well there's easier ways to do that but
the whole idea behind the network is not
to do what's easy and easily accessible
anybody can do that but they live up to
their reputation of grandiosity right
just just this this over the top concept
because as we know in dc comics and i
don't know how translatable this is to
real life but in dc comics ultra wealthy
criminals and and just people who are
super sadistic love over-the-top stuff
they love over-the-top unnecessary
things and so as a result of this that's
how the network functions and so the
question that's being asked here is what
does the joker want with cloned human
tissue and the response of this this
interpol agent is that's the question
right now of course it turns out her
name is isabella hollows uh but
ultimately it's like we don't know what
it is that they want now as kind of an
aside here you sort of switch over to
oracle right and she's of course met by
stephanie brown uh and and essentially
the two of them were just kind of
talking and and doing their thing but in
the midst of a conversation they're
suddenly set upon by a talent now we'll
talk about that here in a second but
when the talent strikes of course it's
basically overtaken pretty easily but in
the end like like batgirl you know
barbara gordon's gear and computers and
all that kind of stuff are all basically
sabotaged and of course at that point
you have cassie who shows up and they
basically fought off the town and the
talon essentially leaves now the big
thing about this and the reason why this
matters is because while the talon
doesn't necessarily speak outside of
saying beware the court of owls once
it's defeated and it's basically sent
away because cassie is so capable at
basically being able to to understand
body language being able to know when a
person is feeling a certain emotion even
though they don't necessarily vocalize
it the first question is asked by
barbara gordon is okay maybe i just
sensed it maybe i just you know maybe
i'm wrong here but cassie i need to know
did that talent feel pain and the
response of cassie is yes and that
indication right there is it's not a
talent now here's the reason why i say
that when scott snyder did the court of
owls basically you had the court of owls
that operated behind the scenes that's
kind of like the criminal organization
the gotham city version was just one
instance of the quarterbacks they
actually operate all over the world
they're an international group as
opposed to just a localized group didn't
really agree with that development i
always loved the idea that the court of
owls was just a gotham city only thing
but regardless that's neither here nor
there the thing about this is that in
order for the uh the the court of owls
to institute its own campaigns they
needed what was basically uh long arm of
the law right like a henchman somebody
to carry out their goals for them to
kill whoever needed to be killed that
was the talent but talons were basically
people who were given a substance when
they were alive and really unwittingly
and then when they would die whether it
was by violent causes natural causes
whatever it was that they would be given
a secondary substance that would
basically resurrect them but they
weren't really capable of feeling pain
they weren't really zombies right they
were just kind of brought back but they
would basically work for the court of
owls because of the fact that this
talent felt pain the indication is this
is not a talent this is somebody
pretending to be a talon in order to
trick us into thinking the court of owls
is behind us now maybe the court of owls
really is but we don't really know right
now all we know is that we switch over
or switch back to jim gordon and
isabella hollows as they're having this
conversation and the question jim gordon
asks is okay like under normal
circumstances you guys would still have
me under lock and key but you guys
wouldn't simply just take the word of a
detective in gotham city whom i trained
and then in turn say well obviously that
means he's innocent that even if you
found some corroborating evidence to
show that i wasn't necessarily at the
scene of the crime when the crime
happened you'd be doing a lot more than
bringing me to some fancy restaurant to
get drinks and the response of isabella
hollows is basically i've been reading
books about gotham city for quite some
time and i've also been reading about
you but what's really cool about this is
she essentially says that what's going
on here is that in her mind gotham city
is not the only place out there that has
problems it's not the only violent city
that exists out there in the world not
even in just the united states that even
in france themselves they have gangsters
and they have criminals they have
murderers they have people that commit
all kinds of crimes but at the end of
the day the important thing here is that
gotham city gains the reputation that it
has because you have like the joker and
you have the penguin and you have
two-face and you've got the bat family
that basically it's a bunch of people
who are committing crimes or even
vigilantes who who are basically dancing
around in costumes and that draws a lot
of attention even though other countries
really have the exact same element
they've got their crazy sociopath mass
murderers like the joker i don't
necessarily know if they're releasing
mass quantities of the toxin into a city
and driving the whole city insane but
the point she's making is you basically
take away the the attention from
everybody else because the resources
that gotham gets other places could use
as well the whole thing about this is
once they get past all that that jim
gordon's like okay so like what's the
point of all this right like what's the
point of you bringing me here and all
that kind of stuff and her stance is
look here's the thing i know what it is
that you're doing like i know you're
trying to track down the joker i don't
know exactly what your motivation is but
i know you're trying to track him down
and in reality the world's better
without the joker in it and so in the
end he says like
and super villains cross the atlantic
every now and then but not often enough
for your current position to be more
than a novelty to your bosses but in
tracking them you've got the shape of a
whole international criminal conspiracy
in your sights the network the joker has
led you to that or the joker has led you
to the realization that there is a
gigantic criminal network operating
behind the scenes the joker's a small
fish what you want is the network and so
obviously that's why you have me here
because you want me to basically engage
or at least to follow the joker and
somewhere along the line because of just
how messy he is he will end up dropping
some information regard regarding the
network something that can be used and
that's why isabella hollows is here
because she's like give me some
actionable intelligence on the network
right and i will let you take the joker
back to gotham city and we'll call it a
day and the question he has is well what
if i can't bring him home right what if
i end up having to kill him and her
response is well things can happen when
apprehending dangerous criminals like
the joker that wouldn't really matter to
us all that matters to us is getting
information on the network but she
basically says like this conversation
has to be between you and me it can't
like this this is this is you and me by
ourselves nobody else is involved here
and that's when jim gordon's like well
that's gonna be kind of a problem and
the reason why is because dane's
daughter is standing right behind her
and then ultimately what ends up
happening here it's kind of nuts that
like isabella hollows jumps up with a
gun knowing who bane's daughter is you
know knowing this is the daughter of
bane like jumps up and it's just like no
right it immediately pulls a gun bane's
daughter grabs this girl hand smashes
her hand and then rips her arm off and
then grabs commissioner gordon squeezes
his neck until he falls unconscious and
is like you're coming with me now when
she has jim gordon in the car
this is the crazy thing cops start
showing up on the scene right there
they're literally here at the port of
marseille they show up on the scene and
they just start like they're they start
shooting at her she literally grabs a
car door uses it as like a shield to
block the bullets and then as the cops
in the helicopter are shooting at her
she actually blocks the shots they end
up killing a couple of their own cops
then she grabs the door and throws it at
the helicopter taking it down like this
girl is a hoss
i absolutely love her now one of the
things to know is this is like the first
time that jim gordon and the daughter of
bane have actually like had any measure
of a conversation they've met before
right but it was largely just one of
those kind of split second moments when
she was like you're in over your head
jim gordon you need to go back home but
when you ask the question like who are
you she's just like i'm vengeance right
and he's like who do you work for like
whose vengeance are you and her response
is like that's what i'm trying to figure
out and so what she says is she had
visited the crime scene in paris right
she visited the crime scene out there
and then basically found that like the
agents that she was with they actually
had their own orders and their orders
were to basically torch the laboratory
but what she realized as the place was
burning is there was one opening that
did not burn there was a segment of the
wall that simply didn't burn and that's
when she realized it was a door and so
getting in that door and going down
that's when she one saw the various dna
samples of different heroes and
different villains and things like that
and then of course some of them as she
says have been taken of course belonging
to the batman but then she realizes or
at least there's a kind of envelope
that's left there uh that essentially
was left by the joker and as she opens
it she gets her origin that the envelope
itself is marked bane mark ii also known
as vengeance and that what had happened
this is where you get the kind of change
in the bane mythos what's going on here
is it looks like the history's being
altered so unless something massive had
changed which i'm not entirely sure that
it did bane as we knew him was basically
a guy in santa prisca who had gained a
reputation for himself and then
ultimately learn about like batman out
you know operating out in gotham city
and having these nightmares about a
giant bat it led him to believe that
like batman represented the ultimate
challenge for bane and so after escaping
santa prisca arriving in gotham city
figuring out batman's identity as bruce
wayne in three months he laid a trap
broke his back and then walked away
having quote unquote conquered his
ultimate challenge you know if you want
to call it that that was seemingly the
origin of him instead what we're told
here and this is really really cool what
we're told here is that the bane project
had gone all too well that bane had
internalized his hatred for his enemies
so deeply he never realized that it was
planted there that he was too clever too
charismatic he could not be controlled
but the leaders of santa prisca value
the symbol of bane what he represented
for our island the way other nations
feared us so they made a deal with the
men in this laboratory to build them a
new bane one they believed they would be
able to control with more advanced
conditioning addicted to venom from
birth i was never meant to question what
i was or why i did what i did i was not
given a story of my own i was taken out
of a tube fully formed with a hatred
planted in my mind i would be unleashed
against any target until i could be
contained again now this is the reason
why this matters where the vengeance of
bane's storyline and the gutenberg
storyline basically revealed that with
with bain kind of rising up through the
ranks of santa prisca and becoming the
quote unquote king of the prison that
taking notice of that the people who
could like the masters of santa prisca
basically put him into the testing
process for the venom formula and of
course he ended up surviving and then
basically escaped santa prisca what this
does is it says what had happened is it
was a kind of secondary alteration that
what the masters of santa prisca wanted
to do was create someone who is capable
of breaking batman just because of how
popular batman was and that in doing so
it would put them on the map and that in
turn they would be able to use bain as
kind of a controllable asset to take out
whoever it is they wanted to take out
what's really interesting is this is
very similar to how wolverine was
handled in weapons plus right that
weapons plus wanted to create a super
soldier wolverine as weapon x was kind
of the perfect soldier and that if the
brainwashing had been complete that
wolverine would have basically been a
living weapon he would have been sent
out by weapons plus to kill whoever it
was they were being paid to have killed
that would have been it that's how bane
would have operated but apparently bain
between his cleverness and all that kind
of stuff that he kind of over overrode
quote unquote the mental conditioning
which is seemingly where his like
irrational fear of bats came from and
that in turn just kind of did his own
thing realizing that subliminal
programming in that way at least as far
as bane went couldn't necessarily be
controlled the scientists went back to
the drawing board and engineered a new
version of bane which is where this girl
comes from so she's the daughter of bane
insofar as she's created from the same
process that made bane but she's not
necessarily his biological daughter or
at least that doesn't necessarily seem
to be the case and so as this discussion
goes on between the two the questioner
of the question of commissioner gordon
is okay so like what what do you want me
for
like you know are you gonna kill me like
what do you want with me so the whole
thing behind this is what she says that
she doesn't want to follow she doesn't
she doesn't want to kill the joker
because that's what she's programmed to
do that being able to make her own
decisions is exactly what bane did that
helped him override the mental
conditioning that had been implanted in
his own mind that at the moment right
now because of her own mental
conditioning she has a drive to destroy
the joker that she would rip his tongue
out right she would tear off his
fingernails and put salt in the wounds
and then she would like she'd kill him
and then bury him in the ground and
leave him there for a week in case
anybody came back and then after that
week she would dig him up and she would
burn his body and that would be it but
she's only she only has a desire to do
that because she's programmed to joker
has never done anything to her it wasn't
like joker killed bane or anything like
that you know the joker didn't take
anything from her that's just her mental
conditioning what she wants is to
basically
to kind of be vengeance for jim gordon
because it's all just psychological her
programming is psychological therefore
if she can uh alter her motivations for
why she's killing the joker on the
psychological level she can break her
psychological conditioning and so what
she wants is for jim gordon to basically
offer some explanation for why it is
that he's going after the joker in the
hopes that she can internalize that
reasoning and then that becomes her
motivation for why she wants to destroy
the joker now the reality is jim
gordon's got every reason to want to
kill the joker
everything that he did to barbara gordon
during during the killing joke and all
that kind of stuff he's got all kinds of
reasons to want to kill this guy and so
it's kind of nuts because at the end of
the day jim gordon's like look i mean
this would work well in theory right i
mean if that's what you want to do do
that right i mean that's that's your
thing the problem is i don't even know
where the joker is you know like i was
hoping to get that information from
isabella hollows but like you killed her
or at least at least you ripped her arm
off before we could and of course you
know interpol ended up taking her away
and the response of of the daughter bane
is like i don't know exactly where the
joker is right that the chief scientist
the man who made me that he had a
private estate on the island of mallorca
i think is how you pronounce that
majorca i think that's how you pronounce
that that word i'm not 100 sure my
spanish has and probably always will be
awful
what little i do know but ultimately a
private laboratory exists there as well
and she says this lead scientist this
chief scientist was not among the dead
and so the clown must have taken him to
achieve whatever it is he's looking to
achieve but we will find the joker there
we will find him in that place and death
will find him as well with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end i absolutely love this joker story
it's just it's really really good uh
yeah we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace